este avión trae 28 toneladas de material
médico desde parís como parte de la
ayuda internacional a la india país que
roza desde hace días los 400.000 casos
diarios
es necesario que la situación mejore en
todos los países para que mejoren todo
el mundo es también por eso que somos
totalmente solidarios con india a bordo
del avión 8 generadores de oxígeno que
pueden alimentar un hospital durante 12
horas seguidas dada la masiva afluencia
de enfermos los hospitales de alrededor
del país han sufrido penuria de oxígeno
camas y material médico lo que aumenta
el número de muertes evitables se
calcula que más de 3 millones de
personas están siendo tratadas contra el
cob y 19 ahora mismo en el país sin
ninguna duda este equipo salvará vidas
espero que la situación mejor en los
próximos días en parte gracias a esta
máquina las muertes que ya superan las
200.000 desde el inicio de la pandemia
han desbordado los crematorios que
funcionan 24 horas
incineramos gente día y noche más de 100
muertos al día los hospitales dejan de
aceptar pacientes porque no tienen más
oxígeno como va a curarse en casa la
gente si no tienen oxígeno ante la
crítica situación sanitaria de india más
de 40 países movilizaron su ayuda para
asistir al país